i think ben's mindset is he's focused on
2021 as we all are and i think we all go
into it and we
we focus now we see where things lead
but beyond that none of us know and uh
obviously ben's at the in the back end
of his career
he was terribly disappointed the way
we ended the way he ended and you know
shortly after the end of the season he
came to us and said listen i want
i want to be back you know of course we
had to work out some things
contractually and and honestly he set
off a nice little surge for us because
we had several players that were able to
come back to us but ben led the way by
taking that pay cut
kevin colbert gm at the steelers from
last week on pftpm that pay cut was five
million dollars that ben roethlisberger
gave up in order to create some caps
base allow the team to maneuver allow
the team to bring back receiver juju
smith schuster among other business they
needed to do and chris you know we were
all over this i think as it unfolded the
idea that the steelers
convinced themselves
we can do this we're not that far away
we're much closer to winning a super
bowl than we are to being a four and
thirteen teams so you have to get it
right 17 games four and thirteen or five
and twelve as the case may be but
uh and and some of that is
delusional maybe i don't know
ben roethlisberger's got to stay healthy
all year can he i don't know
can the steelers muster anything in
their running game i don't know they
drafted naji harris in the first round
but are they gonna have the blocking for
him i don't know but the real question
and kevin colbert admitted this nobody
knows whether or not this has been
roethlisberger's last year i think if
they would win the super bowl he would
do the jerome bettis walk off and at the
sunset thing but anything short of that
i just don't know and i think they don't
know and i think he doesn't know no i
don't think so either i mean i i i like
agreed or if they go to the super bowl
and win that that might be it but like i
think the status of big ben
is predicated on all the other things
you said mike like you know they're
they're the team and where they are can
they run can naj harris actually do some
stuff that way
can the o-line and guys that were
injured last year and now you know they
drafted two rookies in the mid rounds of
this trap can they help out the team
immediately right now can they play that
stock like if they could play that style
of football that you and i have talked
about from the get-go here right of that
buccaneers football
then i go big ben is gonna play two more
years because it's not gonna be on him
every week to have to do stuff and drop
back 45 times a game and make all the
throws but i mean as we've said if they
can get this o line
like together and become somewhat of a
force
it's unbelievable how many parallels
there are to really the buccaneers i
mean there it really is top-notch
defense guys in the front seven that are
mean nasty and fly all over the field
weapons galore wide receiver hard to
match up with all the guys they got
right and then if they can just get that
online power run game aspect of their
team you know
in line to where teams now have to like
whoa we gotta bring a safety down whoa
we can't play nickel we gotta be in a
base defense and stop the run game oh no
now we're one on one with deontay
johnson and chase claypool because we're
worried about stopping the run game if
they can get teams to start playing
football that way against them they're
going to be a beast they they will be
but it's it's the big thing is can they
dominate the line of scrimmage can they
protect big ben
and yeah can he stay healthy is the big
questions i think you're spot on there
our lads.com does a great job of keeping
all of the nfl depth charts updated as
changes are made during the off-season
and you look at the steelers starting
offensive yeah
oh my god well other than david de
castro yeah and zach banner
it's like who are these guys chakuma
okorafor
kevin dodson he's been around yeah uh
and jc hassenauer i mean look these are
guys who are not household names in
pittsburgh much less around the national
football league who are going to be
coming in to try to create the running
lanes for naji harris and the past
protection for ben roethlisberger period
de castro is it he's the one guy who's
left over that you can say oh yeah de
castro he's been part of this pittsburgh
steelers offensive line that's been
better than average for the past several
years now it's work in progress
alejandro villanueva gone marquis
pouncey retired a lot of work to do
kevin feiler signs with the chargers a
guy that you know doesn't it doesn't
jump a name that doesn't jump out but a
guy who who spent a lot of time on the
field starting in multiple positions
over the past couple of years for the
pittsburgh steelers so that that's where
the eggs are in the basket definitely
with the offensive line if that
offensive line works okay if it doesn't
not okay no i i i know it's it's it is
gonna be the key and i think the thing
we watch for to just see what they can
be as a football team you know and and
plus listen with that defense it makes
no sense not to play a style of football
where you run the ball control the clock
a little bit it makes sense for your
quarterback one and the age and the the
the part of co
of his career he's at but two i just
think if you're gonna play complimentary
football
you know the steelers
you want to keep their defense you want
to keep that defense fresh flying around
yeah run the ball got a great defense
make it really hard for another offense
to like whoa with the pressures on us
you know we don't we don't have the ball
a lot they're they're they're running
out the clock on the other side of the
ball you know they just got to find a
way to play complimentary football last
year it made no sense they were playing
defense you know at a pretty high level
but they were playing offense like they
had no defense and they were dropping
back to throw the ball every play and
they went through too many periods of
the year where as good as the defense
was they were put in spots where it was
like well the offense has uh thrown the
ball three times in a row first second
and third down and now you guys are back
on the field there was only 12 seconds
that ran off the game clock and now
you're back on and now they put a drive
together and got a field goal your
offense came back out again and big ben
and company threw the ball three
straight times again and we're on the
field for 14 seconds and now your
defense is back on the field again and
that doesn't make sense that's where
that's complementary football that did
not exist there in pittsburgh last year
and i'm sure that had to drive mike
tomlin crazy and that's why they got to
fix it
okafor started 16 no 15 games at right
tackle last year played in all 16 15
starts at right tackle you take him and
you move him to the left side
it's not as easy as
as it sounds no and and it's been
explained by some in the past in very
graphic ways uh involving uh toilet
paper uh and left hand versus right hand
but uh you know that's gonna be part of
it can he hold up there can zach banner
hold up can david de castro stay healthy
what what are they going to do at center
after all those years of pouncy and bend
together and we thought that the two
were tied together remember the the
images of pouncey and ben roethlisberger
sitting on the bench after the loss to
the browns and the playoffs in that
sense that this is it it's done for both
of them and i think it was more of a
surprise that roethlisberger stayed in
pouncey left than if it had been flipped
but uh and and rothersberger always made
it seem like
the moment pouncey goes he goes so uh
a a a hell of an experiment for the
steelers
again if it works if it works hey maybe
they will be in l.a i don't think it's
there in mid-february it's yeah you're
right it's just a big if that's what it
is i think
they're by the way of the draft and the
guys they got on the roster i think
they're comfortable with the guys it's
just got to be like healthy and can we
get together and set the right attitude
at camp
but you know between okafor
um banner you could put those to a
tackle
datsun who was a young guy who played
guard last year he can play guard you
know then they're gonna have to figure
out the other guard position they
drafted an nfl ready guard uh i wanted
to make sure it's the third round or it
was the third round and kendrick green
at illinois so he'll he could play maybe
mike and be there but the center
position yeah is going to be an unproven
commodity and we'll see who that is but
um yeah that's going to be the key to
their football team i think i mean i
think we're all over it it's going to be
about that aspect can they run the ball
protect him and that's going to be
dictate big ben's future and really the
status of this football team
you've mentioned in the past the
intensity of their training camp
practices i think they need to be even
more intense this year to the to the
point of chippy i i think that that
defense needs to do everything they can
do to draw out the best and the nastiest
of the lines
they're going to be ready to go
sure i agree with you 100
i would think that's
mike tomlin knows what to dial up here
and that this is the kind of group where
hey after the first few days of like
training camp okay the o-line's coming
together a little bit where he talks to
his d-line and he's like you know let's
let's give it to these guys a little bit
i gotta see if they can hold up you know
in week six against the ravens and then
you know the next week we gotta play the
browns and miles garrett and everybody
you know we gotta be we gotta be testing
these guys on a daily basis and see what
they're made of i would think that's
something that mike tomlin is gonna put
his defense to task one during training
camp by the way apologies to matt filer
i said kevin fowler earlier they know
who we mean who's the next quarterback
after 2021
if ben is gone do they go rookie or hey
i'm fascinated by what could happen with
dwayne haskins yeah it's not like the
guy wasn't going to be a first-round
pick no i know he was going to be his
question was where was he coming off the
board washington took him 15th overall
it didn't work out the steelers get him
for nothing and they get this year where
they can
they can just see what he can do yeah
and
you you may end up
getting yourself your future quarterback
without having to draft him in any round
he's a guy that just landed in your laps
after washington gave up on it no i mean
there's talent
there's a there's a big time arm
you know there's size and an athlete
that's better than people wanted to give
him credit for coming out in the draft
as far as dwayne haskins is concerned
and to me
he's the only guy that has potential to
actually really be something as a
starter not to say he will be i don't
know but he's got the potential he does
yeah i don't look at mason rudolph or
joshua dobbs any of those no disrespect
is look i just they're back-up
quarterbacks for me i don't look at them
as like a guy that can be the future
maybe at some point haskins i do think
has that potential but it's all the
other stuff you know let alone he hasn't
played a lot right mike i mean it's just
it's everything now can he dial it in
and be a pro and do all the right things
that we heard kind of the negatives
about in washington can he flip that
around i hope he can
and and remember when he was coming out
in the draft a couple of years ago and
they were saying he lacks mobility we
pointed out here well no he has mobility
behind the line of scrimmage and we
compared him to the big ben right i know
the ability to move left and right and
extend the play that way not necessarily
pull the ball down and take off and run
but extend left and right by time that
way and and he has a guy that he could
watch and learn from in 2021 it creates
an intriguing option for the steelers
beyond this season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports